he looks way younger on the left what
are you talking about he turned into a
vampire is what happened technically he
was younger he got bigger and he has
more color in the middle of it he's
taller by now
with no info no context how do you feel
about this photo I already know dude I
already know this guy wait is that have
you seen this you haven't seen this guy
it's not equal this guy's he's very uh
popular on the fitness YouTube algorithm
that guy's kind of jacked oh wait is
that Brian he's lean yeah I think oh oh
dude this guy's [__] dope okay I
thought it was like a um like a like a
beginning to a gay origin but that's his
dad and his son how come you're not
wearing wife beater that's a weird pose
like that objectively why are their
shirts all wet no they're um why are
they looking like at the camera like
forlorn and [__] so Hannah's like deep
diving into this guy right now and so he
was uh owner of venmo he sold it oh wow
oh that's that's who he is huh yeah oh
wow and then he he went off on this
Quest on trying to find out how humans
can achieve longevity and reverse aging
so he spent like two mil on just like
being the science experiment
and experimenting experimenting with
diet
exercise homoerotic photography homo
erotic family photography yeah and
that's the most important thing people
don't know this but it reduces yeah
you're aging a lot less orphans when you
get jacked off by your dad we gotta take
a photo shoot it's like an inch away
from the wiener yeah he's like right
there
biohacker upward motion his dad is at
least mounting him yeah it looks like
it's going down it's like low now he's
got his like dad and son into it I don't
say data so they're doing it as a group
or something yeah they are yeah so he
yeah he is the the tech uh is it working
like he's like he seriously doesn't work
I mean I mean he claims that it works
does he have like certain like
biomarkers that's kind of it's very
scientific also like the thing is um huh
it's legit it's legit he's going he's
just the palest man ever institutes to
be consistently uh what do you call it
like um monitors yeah monitored from
progress to whatever and I guess there's
certain things that you know you they
can they can test their skin organs body
whatever and be like oh you have the
cardiovascular of a 19 year old versus
like what like this is the average of
like someone who's this age yeah so then
a lot of his stuff he's reversed that
aging like and then they'll be like yeah
you have uh a stamina of a young person
he looks really young and he's in really
good shape he just looks like a vampire
that's the problem yeah look young well
it's because he's a soulless Ginger he
just looks his skin is like it's it's
like porcelain bro there's no more thing
out of the sun part of it is that why no
he's just Ginger you know he's just like
posing like that will make you live
longer yeah no Melanie he looks like
that chick from Doctor Strange yeah yeah
yeah for sure for sure for sure the time
Stone keeper chick it is Brian Johnson
he's the multi-millionaire uh Tech CEO
it was it was Braintree that he was the
uh he owned Braintree I thought it was
venmo no it's uh those are different
guys braintree's like it's like a venmo
okay I think it's a Braintree helps
venmo work in conjunction with other
credit cards and stuff well that's not
them and like I did see it before and
after though because like right now he
just looks like a 45 year old lesbian
lady that's into yoga but then um when
you see him like what he used to look
like till now oh big difference that's a
huge difference wow he looks healthier
the main thing that he does is he swaps
blood with his son oh that guy yeah so
is the sun [__] getting older and or
getting efficient no actually his son
they said his son is experiencing
benefits from like frequent donation too
yeah really yeah that like but you were
talking better like they'll they'll link
up and he'll like replace his blood with
his son's blood and then the dad will do
it too whoa they're all like yeah
they're all like dialysis triple triple
[__] and that's why they probably
took that big picture but no one wants
the Dazz book homo erotic vampire love
like if you're gonna spill some blood
spill my dad's yeah yeah but I think
it's that's I think that practice is
based on a study they did with it says
they they did that with rats and then
the rats so here's the human trial very
clear benefits of being healthier but
they said so far there's no conclusive
evidence that it works with humans
because there's no way to test him on
how he would have been I also wonder if
it's like uh if you get your kids blood
if it's it needs to be post puberty
like like if taika had more testosterone
in his blood like would that make me
more youthful versus I just [__] turn
into a baby
you start sucking on your thumb I lose
muscle tone and I'm like yeah like a
baby chick
they said that when they did it with
rodents they uh so they made them share
the circulatory system and the older
rodents uh improved in cognitive
function metabolism bone structure wow
and the younger subjects showed positive
effects from frequent blood donation
which I don't understand how that's even
a thing
yeah so stem cells that's crazy yeah
that's testosterone
in the nuts oh [__] that's insane but
then like this I guess like some of the
science like City of Hope National
Medical Center
um they say they have not learned enough
to suggest this is a viable human
treatment like everyone should do it and
then we think he would have looked like
a lesbian anyway the scientist study
show
[__] says to me it's gross
evidence-free and relatively dangerous
well he is testing a lot of things right
yeah he's doing a lot what's the control
group
so here I'll give you a list so he
follows an ultra strict routine that
includes supplements rigorous exercise
low calorie vegan diet carefully
calculated teeth brushing
um sleep patterns and he's even hooked
up to a machine that keeps count of his
uh oranges new black feeling erections
during the night that's my fight camp
where he's doing nothing different wait
did you say did you say erections during
the night yeah vigorous boners what is
the point of that maybe it's a
circulation thing
he says he gets raging boners at like 3
A.M
we'll get the random refill he claims
that that the expensive treatments are
uh their yielding results he it's he
says that he has a heart function of a
37 year old and skin that resembles a 28
year old and not to brag but I get
boners all
nightable I mean it's like it depends
because it gets pretty good how's the
skin is it gets really big 50 or 60. oh
he's like 45 47 yeah 45 yeah damn I
thought this was really interesting
though because like you know when you
want to conduct studies like this it
takes so much time and money yeah and
then a team right but then like when you
have that unlimited funding that he
could actually do the tests that some of
these scientists want to do on a human
being it's not the money it doesn't have
to wait and they don't have to wait so
he might be doing a lot of things
in favor of human health it's gonna be
cool to see what happens what he does we
can see if some of these things work or
if they don't work it's like Trump said
he's like it's called right to try
right I think that's pretty good right
it's called right to try
it's kind of similar to PRP where they
dry your blood out and then they spin it
and they separate the uh plasma from the
blood and they inject it right back into
you it seems very similar it's a very
sexy science I I did something
um that I thought well I I got a Dexter
scan you guys know what that is no so it
scans like your body fat percentage or
like how much muscle you have your bone
and all that stuff and the one
interesting find that I have is so I've
been lifting weights since I was 15. I'm
39 now so that's 24 years wow and then
uh on the dexa scan
um this was for like another series that
we did and this was information that
wasn't really part of the series because
part of the series it was just more
about how much weight did I lose and all
that
one on the bone density like my bone
density was actually like literally off
the charts wow which was cool like it
was like like you know how like you got
thick bones bro well like you know like
standard you know like standard
deviation it's like in one it hits like
I don't know 95 or something and 97 and
then by the third or whatever it's like
a hundred percent uh-huh so like if
you're like one standard deviation away
from the middle like and then two two
standard deviations is like pretty much
the whole population mine was four yeah
wow and I think it's just because of
lifting weights but heavy weights like
heavier weights for like ever since I
was like a teen wow that it caused my
bones to be like so dense I wonder if
other uh weight lifters are for sure
power power lifters or whatever would
have the same yeah because she saw it
she was like
it's literally that won't even print out
where your bone density is because it's
like too far sick at a range yeah like
when you get diagnosed with like
osteoporosis who broke the scale or
whatever they tell you you need to be
you need to start lifting weights yeah
tell the first thing uh well because um
because it builds bone density do you
wish that you could lift weights with
your dick for all those years I wish
that'd be so cool though
like wiener barbells and then he did one
of these
the nurses see the results and they pass
out
there oh my God I can't read it oh my
forced it
longevity is muscle mass so if you have
like the more muscle mass you retain
over the years they show like a graph of
like uh
a correlation between like the drop off
and muscle mass and your life and also
grip strength too they say grip strength
you got weak grip you're probably gonna
die early a good thing I jack off hard
that's right because you can't tell them
to the jerkers go with the spoils you
need a grip heart he spends two million
per year on this process wow yeah but
the crazy thing is the sad thing is that
he is California based so wouldn't it be
kind of Bittersweet if he died from like
a follow-on robbery or something
dude it sounds like you need an effort
from a 19 time parolee being released
again it's like it's like all this
[__] effort oops you still a living
Cali idiot but I I bet and a doofy get
out to do what he's doing you probably
need such a rigorous schedule like think
about all the things that he needs to do
like drawn blood here brush his teeth
yeah yeah his brushing teeth routine
that's cool and you gotta put on a
[__] dick monitor before you go to
bed yeah dude it is great that he's
doing this you can watch that thing yeah
I don't think so it's also um it's so
sweaty last night
like timed right so then he needs to get
x amount of hours of sleep he has like a
perfect sweet sleep condition thing
routine do you think I like sometimes
during the day he's like [__] what I
sign up for this [__] he plays like a
cheat day like all right today I'm not
gonna do whatever yeah I'm gonna extend
my life by 30 years today this freaking
shovels up I think it is really cool
that he does he's doing this for the
benefit of everyone yeah like people can
benefit from this data which is why the
[__] are you talking about which is why
I want him in [__] Glamor Shots with
this [__] it's about him but others
scientists are going to be like if it's
only one guy we need to do this 15 more
times to figure it out but you know like
people are gonna steal his his info yeah
well there's there's still his work yeah
I don't really think it's open source
but like I feel like um
there's a lot of people that [__]
hate this dude dude this guy's doing for
him just with I mean just just with
anything that's like what if he lives to
150 I think that's gonna be the future
though
a lot of us are going to extend our
lifespan dude my grandma just died on
Friday
94 years old no way it was awful oh no
but it's fine no thank you but I didn't
mean to bring it up like I'm just saying
like that's no way to live like the way
she was living was no way to live I'm
glad that she's dead but I mean 94
swimming strong coherent like that's
different right
of course no it no it's no it's sad but
it really was like a Slow Burn yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the that's
the part that I don't want no it's just
[__] because he still looks like [__]
that's the thing I mean I think he does
too like can I see a picture like he
like I don't think he looks as young as
he probably feels he looks like the bad
guy I think it's the picture the picture
is really bad I mean if he released that
that must be a picture he's proud of
like Richard Branson looks good he looks
happy like he has a lot of Vitality he's
70 something but he feels like he just
has his like feeling he looks like
Nosferatu yeah bro yeah he just he looks
45 whatever he's doing he looks like he
looks like a ghoul yeah but Ross
yeah but to be fair though he looked
like 55 yeah so oh oh so you got to see
so it is working oh I see so he was like
a fat guy that was kind of but what if
it was all the other stuff like what if
it wasn't the blood transfer I mean it
yeah be on a diet for a little bit just
be like him losing weight and he's like
oh look great he's a massive amount of
weight you actually look like that can I
cut wake that's what I look like when
you lose weight you look younger you
literally look younger then you lose too
much weight then you look old then you
look too old yeah that's true I feel the
too fast and it's kind of like straight
yeah you're like a skinny saggy Grandpa
even if you're too lean right here you
go too lean for too long that's the
progression
low-key what's the progression okay he
looked better on the left that's not a
fair lining though he's kind of good in
the middle left to right is the time is
the timeline so he's like doing a
[__] Ted Talk that's when he started
he looks way younger on the left what
are you talking about he turned into a
vampire is what happened technically he
was younger he got bigger and he has
more color in the middle of it he's
taller by now
he's tall he went from gray orange to
pale I don't know about all this weird
[__] no this isn't working just [__]
lift a little bit away so walk around a
little bit about two billion dollars a
year I could do so much in crypto this
guy's barely even making any games make
himself look like [__] dude LeBron James
doesn't even spent two million I just
hope I just hope he has the guts at some
point to to literally just go it's not
[__] working man like if it really
isn't like if it's hurting him yeah like
I hope he doesn't try to fake the funk
and be like guys it's a breakthrough
everyone should try it but the longer he
does it though the more likely that's
gonna happen
his end game is to find the best routine
and conditions that he could just so
like the testing and all that is to find
a result once he does find a routine and
condition then he goes okay so this is
the optimum like yeah like thing because
right now he's like
there's so many conflicting things of
like what is the optimum diet what is
the optimum exercise what do people
actually need so like I think these
experiments is to figure out what that
everybody's Baseline should be for real
Health we're a result space culture who
got into bodybuilding after the example
Arnold right Arnold brought a lot of
people in because Arnold's like
objectively look at me [__] I
look great and so everyone's like I'm
gonna do that [__] this guy's making
people go maybe I should just die early
[Music]
foreign